hi it's Lisa trigger I cannot stop
smiling because I'm at the AVN Awards in
Vegas I trick Comedy Central to Lennon
we do red carpet interviews I have zero
experience but I'm here we'll ask
questions and meet the biggest names in
porn this is my first ABN do you have
any advice oh yeah pace yourself cuz
it's gonna keep getting more wild hey
dream I've been drinking whiskey like
over that's up keeping mellow then I
mean smoke weed if that's what helps
what advice do you offer me it's my
first day BMS learn to gag can you give
me a porn name
give you a fun yeah candy tips pretty
titties Betty Botta cream soda lies a
big titty I see you and I see like Gina
Valentina that's so nice
like like because it's such a sweet name
you already have a four-star name you
gotta be in your name that's already
sexy sexy are worth like 10 points in
Scrabble what's the biggest lion born
that I'm a Raging Bitch no that's
actually true what's the biggest
secret important the biggest secret in
porn squirts not real but I squirt and I
feel like it's real I'm not trying too
hard let me say porn squirt okay so hard
squirt is Pete what's the biggest kept
secret important we use like sponges in
our vagina when we have our period so
engage so that's a very good secret
thank you for sharing that move on you a
lot really pretty girls will approve on
you all the time I've cream high stools
usually aren't real what is it a
different substance
yeah usually they use thank you Senate
bill thank you if you can make her
bodily fluids taste like anything what
flavor would they be steak steak yeah
sure why not
all right a ribeye I like rib eyes
ribeye Jezz okay gotcha
really that was not the answer I was
expecting what did you think she was
gonna say question first
Oh also good also good you know every
bitch that's the only pineapple a drink
pineapples
do you ever masturbate with your own
movies no hell no only the scenes where
I like know that I came all the time
really mature they're like twice a week
when I watch myself I'm like oh I don't
know why I'm making up face no I hate my
own voice absolutely all the time yeah
my first anal just got released and I'm
kind of digging that because it's the
only time I can watch myself get what's
something you haven't filmed that you
want to film an official game back
didn't gain Riggs gangbang like a game
thing but like I'm the only one thinking
is there something that you haven't
filmed yet they are dying to fail you
know a bukkake you've never done that no
I would really like to film a scene in
zero gravity hey what was your last
doodle search soil fertility amazing
what are you planting nothing
that's a wrap from the ABN red carpet
I've had a dream night and I found my
friends for the night so I am out of
here
bye
[Music]
you